At the end of episode one, we were ambushed by Vordt, watchdog of the Boreal Valley.
And what follows is a really incredible boss fight.
Such a huge part of it for me, was the music.
In phase 2, the boss becomes enraged and your heart rate steps it up
and the music just matches it all the entire time.
Vordt, is an ourtider knight of the Boreal Valley
Every outrider knight one day devolves into a beast constantly hounded by
Pontiff Sulyvhan's black eyes.
The black eye ring reads:
"Knights who peer into the black orb are lured into the battles of death
transformed into frenzied beasts.
No wonder the Pontiff only provides these rings to those dispatched to foreign lands."
Oh, this is phase 2
Gonna blame that loss on the fact that I switched the torch accidentally
I just mashed the d-pad badly.
the next fight went much more smoothly.
Gotta say,
these first two boss fights have been on Bloodborne's level of boss fights, seriously,
they're really great.
Although I do hope that they give the bosses more hit points in the final build.
I think everyone beat it a bit too easily.
Vordt was guarding Lothric's only exit
and since he's referred to as watchdog, and
outrider knight,
It's logical that he exists to stop people, particularly an undead perhaps?
Reaching that valley and leaving Lothric.
We can see some icy mountains, some castles and valleys in the distance after all and that's where we're headed
Cause look who's back.
I'm seeing a pattern here.
The gargoyles of Darksoul's 1
Where deamons that appeared all over Anor Londo
Responding  to a ring of light.
And  pulling the undead from the decrepit undead lands.
To the city of the Lords.
And on the flip side
The gargoyles of Darksouls 3
See a character raising a ringed banner of Lothric
and carry our Unkindled down off the High Wall to the decrepit Undead Settlement
to hunt down the Lords that Emma said fled Lothric
My point is that it's another example of antithesis that I've described in other videos
where core tropes of the series aren't really being changed, they're being flipped.
Add travelling down instead of up to that list
Yoel: (sobbing) "Please, grant me death. Undo my shackles
Ohh...
Ohh, then it's true...
A Champion of Ash, as I live and breathe.
To be in your presence is a great honour.
I am Yoel of Londor, a pilgrim, as you can see, only...
Somehow, I've failed to die as was ordained
Well, perhaps my calling lies elsewhere.
Say, Champion of Ash, how does the idea of taking me into your service strike you?
I was once a sorcerer. Surely I can be of use.
Ohh, I am honoured, truly.
I should be dead, yet you have granted me purpose anew.
I, Yoel of Londor, do solemnly swear myself to you."
(Vaati) Yoel will now appear at our Firelink Shrine but his fellow pilgrims all died reaching for Lothric
And if they were prophesied to die on this journey then why did they come?
Going back to our Shrine for a moment, we meet this guy
"Mm, Unkindled, are we...
And fast on the trail of the Lords absconded?
Then these red eyes are for you.
Use them to pillage embers, and briefly heighten your strength, for your duty.
What else are unkindled ashes good for?"
(laughing)
(Vaati) Oh, and I didn't tell you guys this last episode but back in Lothric, I met a thief named Greirat
Greirat: "Ahh, you're no jailer, are you?
No, no, you're from far away. And judging by the bell...
You must be some of that unkindled ash."
Long story short, he asks you to give a ring to a woman named Loretta, someone he's presumably close to
Greirat: "...Do your part, and I'll do mine."
(Vaati) The Undead Settlement is full of thieves like Greirat, who climb all over buildings and hang from roofs
and are damn good professionals at ambushing you
I thought I was being careful when I explored this dark building and then...
Afterwards, I found Greirat's Loretta
Greirat: "Heavens, she was already dead...
Thank you. I-I'm not surprised, though.
Hmm, almost a relief, really."
(Vaati) After dramatically falling to the ground - I love the new emotes, by the way
- I reloaded the area and I realized that you can send Greirat
on a thieving quest to get some new loot in his inventory
and when he returns, he sells awesome weapons like the Pontiff Curved Sword
and other things like this Zweihander, for example
But back to the Settlement, this is an area of wood, of fire worship and the burning, imprisonment,
restrainment and torture of hollows.
And a common problem in Soul's universes is actually what to do with the overflow of undead.
Killing them is never permanent so putting them in cages is a pretty popular solution
Well, a partial solution
From the worker's attire, we learn that they're also working here to dissect and bury undead
Although apparently, the ceremonial significance of such work is forgotten
This guy, for example, uses his pot of undead remains as a weapon
This fight turned into a really cool moment, though, where I quickly noticed a remaining fire barrel
and used it to my advantage
Another exciting moment was in the sewers with low health, no Estus and some rats in a tunnel
I can't believe it didn't attack at the end there.
I got so lucky
But this, this was probably the most terrifying moment
So about now, you might be wondering which tower is this episode titled after?
And it's that one
If you listened carefully here, you could hear the thwack of a giant bowstring being released
There's a giant on the top of that tower and he's firing arrows at us and now that I've explored
the majority of the area, I know exactly where it is so it's time to get him to stop
Most of you probably know this but characters are one of the most important parts of the series for me
And the knight that we meet in this tower, along with the whole experience within it,
is going to be a memorable experience for a lot of us
Siegward: "Hmm...
Mmmmmm...
Hmm... Mmm...
Oh!
Pardon me, I was absorbed in thought.
I am Siegward of Catarina
To be honest, I'm in a bit of a pickle.
Have you ever walked near a white birch, only to be struck by a great arrow?
Well, if I'm not mistaken, they come from this tower
Whoever it is, I'm sure I can talk some sense into them
But I have to find a way up, and that's just the trouble.
This lift only goes down, you see, and...
Well, that doesn't get me anywhere...
Hmm... Mmm...
Giant: "Who are you?
I help anytime."
(Vaati) There is the white birch that Siegward was talking about.
This giant will now only attack enemies whenever you're near it
Siegward: "Hmm..."
(Vaati) Did you hear that?
(Vaati) There
Siegward: "Hmm... Mmm...
Ah, oh!
Don't disappear like that. You had me downright worried.
But thanks to you, an epiphany has struck me square in the head.
I've unravelled the riddle of this inscrutable lift!
(laughing)"
"On some days, I begin to doubt myself.
I went up the tower, so I thought, then somehow ended up here.
I'm not exactly sure what happened.
Anyhow, do you see that? That humungous beast?
I'm no coward, and I've a steady hand, but that thing makes my skin crawl.
Now, now, think twice before you go down that road."
"I could try talking some sense into him...
No, I think not. He's far too over-heated.
I've got to use my head. And think.
Hmm... Mmm..."
(Vaati) In this moment, I knew exactly what to do.
It's the flip-side of what happened in Lost Izalith so long ago now.
Siegmeyer: "For now, I go. Don't be slow!
(yelling)
Come on, over here you fiends!
Perish, foul creatures!
I am Siegmeyer of Catarina and you shall feel my wrath!"
Siegward: "No! You should have waited!
Well, it's too late now.
I, Siegward of the Knights of Catarina, fight by your side!
(yelling)"
Siegward: (panting) That was quite the performance.
But you mustn't get in over your head.
We Unkindled must put our duties first.
But for the moment, we've a toast to make.
To your valour, my sword, and our victory together.
Long may the sun shine!
(laughing)"
"Well, I'm going to have myself a little nap.
The only thing to do, really, after a nice toast.
(laughing)"
(Vaati) Even recording this narration after playing, watching it again just makes me grin like an idiot.
This is Siegmeyer or Siegward, I suppose now.
A character who featured in Prepare to Cry so long ago, which is the series that got this channel off the ground.
The channel that led to me being able to play the game early and share it with you guys.
And I don't know about you but it's pretty special seeing this guy again
and I can't wait to see where his journey ends up this time
At the very least, we know that there is one amazing character in this game, right?
More familiar faces are in episode 3 which is going to be the final pre-released playthrough and
the one with the most significant lore implications that we've seen yet
I'm very confident I've found some stuff that was really hidden
and if you're watching all these spoilers, it's stuff you probably haven't seen yet
So thank you, as always, for watching and I hope you're liking it.